sup glider fans I'm here with the myth  the legend  the wookie Chewbacca what's up Chewie  I do you mind if I call you Chewie  awesome Chewbacca it is what is a  Wookiee certainly clears that up  you know we know about the Chewbacca  that invites these Star Wars but what  does Chewbacca do in his free time bit  of a thrill seeker a my man  [Music]  serious question when you were training  to be a pilot did everyone call you the  rookie Rookie it wasn't that bad of a  dad joke Oh looks like I gotta wrap this  up I'm so sorry uh you know was a real  pleasure meeting you hit it  [Music]  you know I I got to be honest I I feel  really bad but I have no idea what he's  saying yeah what he said  [Music]